okay so next I want to talk about the
the meta learning aspect and another
hypothesis that's important to deal with
how the world changes so but a learning
is something really hot and cool these
days but actually started several
decades ago my brother and I have been
working on this in the early 90s and
actually was
Sammy's PhD subject and and what it's
about really is about having multiple
time scales of learning or multiple time
scales of iterative optimization like
computation so typically you would have
an inner loop like normal learning an
outer loop like evolution which
optimizes whatever the inner loop is is
producing and so in this way we can talk
about the evolution outer loop with
individual learning in the loop or we
can talk about in the life of an
individual lifetime learning as the
outer loop and individual adaptation to
a new environment as the fastest time
scale and the thing that's cool about
meta learning is that allows us to
explicitly optimize for generalization
and in particular it can be used to
explicitly optimize for out of
distributional ization right if the
agent sees multiple environments and we
can we can train it's slow time scale
meta parameters so that it will
generalize well to new environments now
there is the question of that I
mentioned earlier
what kind of hypothesis can we make
about these changes in distribution and
because underlying physics means that
typically an action by an agent is going
to be localized in space and time we can
assume that the changes in distribution
correspond to are caused by or the
consequence of an intervention by an
agent that acts on just a few causes or
a few mechanisms that relate variables
with each other so this extends
hypothesis that was proposed by shop
cough and collaborators of independent
mechanisms and what they mean here is in
emotionally independent meaning that the
the relationships between variables the
mechanisms the conditional distributions
are independent in a sense that what you
learn from one doesn't tell you anything
about another one and so if something
changes in the world one of these
mechanisms changes one of the
conditional distributions corresponding
to say one of the nodes in this graph
it's like a graphical model for example
if something like this changes due to an
intervention
you only need to adapt the the part of
the model that corresponds to the change
so for example if I put on some
sunglasses the data that I'm getting at
my my retina eyes is very very different
but it can be explained by a tiny change
which is this one variable that you know
changes its value from 0 to 1 so that
that's really interesting because if we
have such hypothesis and we have a good
representations of the interactions
between all those high-level variables
then very few bits would be needed to
account for those changes and this very
few observations needed to adapt or
infer what what has happened and this we
can get good out of this visualization
so so the idea is since out of this
visualization can be obtained if we have
a right decomposition of knowledge we
can use out of this fishing performance
as a training signal for factorizing
knowledge ok so we did some work in that
direction there's a paper called a meta
transfer objective for learning to
disentangle causal mechanisms where we
applied this idea in a very simple
settings where you have just two
variables a and B or say for rivals a B
X Y and a is the cause of B but the
learner doesn't know and you might
observe just X and y which are simple
like rotations of a and B and it turns
out that if you have to write
decomposition if you if you look at the
the right way of factoring the Joint
Distribution between
and be the one in which we have P of a
the cause multiplied by P of B given a
for for the effect given the cause then
when there's a change in distribution
due to an intervention on the cause the
the learner that has the right model
will adapt much faster doesn't need as
much data so the x-axis on this thing is
the amount of data that the learner
needs to recover from a change in P of a
and it turns out that you can also use
this to learn about how to map the X Y
which is things like the pixels that
don't have a causal structure to the A's
and B's that are the high-level
variables that have causal structure
because again the same remark as I did
earlier with the consciousness prior
which does not apply on the pixel level
the assumption that these tidal
variables are causal does not work on on
things like pixels and you can't really
find a pixel that is a cause of another
pixel right so it's not the right space
for doing things we had a more recent
paper called learning neural causal
models from a known interventions where
we extend these ideas to larger graphs
in such a way that we can avoid the
exponential explosion of the number of
graphs that need to be considered by
permit rising in a factorized way the
distribution over graphs and one of the
things we find is that in order to
really facilitate the learning of the
column structure the learner should try
to infer what was the intervention on
which variable was the change performed
and that's something we do all the time
like most of the time at least my brain
is trying to figure out what was the
cause of what I've observed or that
explained the change that I am seeing so
we tested these ideas on various small
graphs and we were able to find that
actually this works quite well and
better this than the commonly used
causal induction methods but more
importantly the way that we are
attacking this problem is something
that's very deep learning
friendly in the sense that we just
defined an overall objective some
regularization terms usual things and we
do green descent on it